welcome to t-fat kz kids a few
few housekeeping notes for you uh west
palm beach
going down close out this shitty year
december 31st to january 2nd
um with this crew in west palm beach
florida those shows almost sold out
and then san marcos texas january 29th
through the 30th
two shows friday to show saturday
there's limited seating
limited capacity in san marcos texas at
a place called the mark
um we're excited for this one but those
shows will sell so get on it right now
kiddos
san marcos texas january 29th through
the 30th
at tfatkay.com also this friday
midnight thick boy smiley face gear
drops thinkboy.com
midnight get you some this is gonna go
fast we're talking about thick
smiley face gear my favorite uh
thing we've done yet thickboy.com this
friday
at midnight get you some this podcast is
brought to you by
my favorite supplements on the planet
i've talked about on every goddamn show
i do we're talking about on it on it.com
fighter 10 off the entire damn site you
got protein powder glutamine krill oil
joint oil
uh total gut health you got fitness gear
kettlebell streaming fitness
uh freaking sandbags for your ass
battle ropes we got it all uh my
favorite coffee [ __ ] yeah coffee it's
black rifle collab with on it
they got extra caffeine in there [ __ ]
yeah it's my favorite coffee on the
planet it's a dark roast
get you some save temps off everything i
just mentioned the best supplements the
best coffee the best training gear on
it.com10 off you're welcome
what is happening it's cracking white
black
yeah dude i'm the minority in this
mother
how you feel uh you know it's cool
watching my words
uh we have special guests in the
building dumbfounded also known by his
friends
and your mom uh just as dumb yeah yeah
yeah dumbfounded is a long word you know
i'm saying it's kind of an old word you
know from like 19
yeah 40s and [ __ ] i'm dumbfounded like
no one really says that no more you know
i mean but
it's unique because i got it when i was
14 and oh hell yeah
you got it when you're 14 just from from
rapping yeah yeah freestyling and you
know going through terrible rap names
and then landed on somehow dumbfounded
which is still terrible
i think it's dope it's weird it was like
when you get a nickname so young and
then you go into like
you know your third you're like in your
mid-30s and [ __ ] and you still got like
a
i guess it doesn't matter you got
ludicrous and like fabulous yeah you
know i was like
like so bad joe cats just kind of like
soak it in and that's who you are you
know
that's who you are you kind of make the
name yeah exactly yeah well
they said uh chalice gambino picked his
name just by going online you can do
like those games where it goes yeah you
know uh what would your rap name be
and then you just randomly hit it and
gave him childish games yeah it was a it
was a wu-tang
wu-tang uh name generator yeah
that's what he did and just randomly
yeah exactly because he's
dropping the chalice gambino just going
by gambino uh no just glover
glover yeah his first name's uh donald
yeah he doesn't wanna be known as josh
gambino anymore donald is not a lit name
yeah i know i'll just go by glover too
yeah maybe just don or donny or
something johnny yeah johnny
yeah yeah i mean
that's a different connotation gambino
is like you know like you've got a
scarface poster
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
but he uh i mean he's a i mean he's
winning
emmys and [ __ ] so he's probably like hey
let's go buy glover yeah don't don't
don't be calling me gambino anymore you
know yeah like atlanta
that atl show is huge it's very very
popular yeah
really do you watch tv you know i love
watch tv
you're a great interviewer yeah do you
watch that man you have a tv
i heard you go about dumbfounded who's
screening these
no questions television i grew up on
television like so i feel like my whole
personality is based off on like
sitcoms from the 90s yeah you know i was
like
you're mid-30s i'm 34. yeah okay yeah so
it's just like
you know my parents were always working
so i grew up like i just grew up on
television like a latchkey child you
know what i'm saying just
uh watching sitcoms tgif you know yeah
yeah that's all that great yeah step by
step yeah
family matters
yeah yeah so all those shows pretty much
what raised me you know yeah
yeah and i feel like now there's nothing
really like
yes where the kids have now there's like
modern family and [ __ ] but not
really modern family's done well i'm
just saying like that was a long one
yeah like the sitcom vibe is is
no more yeah yeah yeah can you watch
stuff like euphoria now
yeah euphoria is like the hot gen z show
yeah i love you foreign i wouldn't let
like i wouldn't want my kid at 10 or 11
minutes like kids
no dude it is intense a lot of sex
tons yeah drugs and a lot of dicks like
dudes like kids
like this what they do it's a very woke
show though i would say you know
because it's like it speaks to the
landscape of like how [ __ ] is now you
know what i'm saying kids are just
up on everything yeah all the pronouns
and everything like they're up on
everything so
yeah like you know when when i was a kid
like you know we play
again not my terminology but we play
smear the queer
like if you went if you went into high
school and i like smear the queer like
how [ __ ] i know right wow yeah
they're like
unbelievable i've never even heard of
that i've never heard of it i'm like
really seven up so what is that
it's basically like so you have a
football and there's like whatever eight
to ten your friends
and you would throw the ball in the air
and like it's like first person a
thousand points
you throw the ball in there like 100
points and then he
whoever catches the ball it would have
to get to the other end zone so it's
like
you can like capture the flag capture
the fact basically with the football
they call it smear the queer but now
like
you know we didn't know it's kids we
didn't even know what referred yeah yeah
it's just what they would call it yeah
for sure but in that euphoria show like
one of the main characters the main
character
is uh what's his name
she's the main character but the other
like
main character had like a big storyline
yeah transgender
girl i think yeah transgender girl
pronouns
actual transgender yeah yeah that's her
main
like love interest in the show yeah
daiya's main level yeah yeah yeah it's
but it's fantastic
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then the the dad
of like the star
quarterback is like hooking up against
spoilers in three
two one it's been out for [ __ ] years
the dad is hooking up with the
transgender girl
yeah yeah it's crazy it's it's how how
old is the transgender girl
high school yeah [ __ ] is wild and this
is a kid show too so
dude it is different really yeah yeah
but it's such a good show like it's so
well done
yeah yeah yeah you're so right i didn't
even really think about it the shows
we watched was is just completely
different i'm like what did
what completely looked forward to like
we looked forward to
tgif it was awesome it was yeah
you're just like [ __ ] well the
wholesome's dope like
that's still like wholesome dope like my
son this morning woke up because the
the elf on the shelf [ __ ] and i taped
the elf to the wall
and i was like the elf's been bad dude
look what santa did to him so i taped
him to the wall
and then put my son's like clothes on
the wall too
and he was like oh but it's just like
the wholesome of that
he's like oh dad the elf messed up like
yep dude yeah just like all of that
yeah this is wholesome yeah yeah there's
no you know yeah
there's no you know you know corona knew
some
the chaos and this one this show is
called euphoria euphoria yeah
she wants it's so well done dude yeah
and drake what i like
the co-producer oh yeah i'm telling you
would love it oh okay
y'all think y'all know me huh yeah
and they're shooting uh season two
should come soon
yeah they're starting to film season two
right now they just released a short
like part one
yeah a few days of no a few weeks ago i
feel like everything popping right now
like on netflix and hbo
showtime everything's pretty dark like
it's a serious dock
or it's dark what about dark comedy like
they don't they don't beat around the
bush with [ __ ] no more you know what i'm
saying
like like back in the day it was just
like oopsie you know like yeah yeah
now it's just like you get to the grid
of it and you know i don't know but i
feel like wholesome is making a comeback
though you know because all the
nostalgic [ __ ] is making a comeback
you know yeah like studios aren't
writing anything original they're just
recreating wholesome [ __ ] you're saying
kind of well they're also rebooting
like the classic [ __ ] like saved by the
bell they rebooted the chat
roseanne i haven't seen it but i know
what they did is like updated it in a
way way they make
the kids more modern in the way they're
like woke to
the top uh you know it's kind of a
bummer is it like
like i'm all for that but when you watch
it like goddamn dude
it's just like it's not different yeah
yeah and it's on the way
it's on hb uh peacock peacock yeah
what's peacock
there's a lot of there's so many
streaming services right now
it's hard i feel like i don't know when
if that's gonna ever like
burst like how many things can you
subscribe to so
someone you know maybe netflix someone's
gonna come in
maybe it's disney plus someone's gonna
come and just start eating it up and you
can have one
service eventually they need that for
only fans you know what i mean like you
can get like 20 subscriptions with this
package deal or something yeah they
really do
i i'd be surprised with how many people
subscribe to so many
different only fans like it's happening
you know that's huge
yeah like i'm always like this close to
subscribing to the only fans like every
day
like just like yeah
now right like it used to be just kind
of promiscuous like
oh i heard it didn't start off
promiscuous i heard it started as like
just like a service for like people to
connect with their and that's kind of
what it is now though
like i feel it's going more towards that
way yeah michael b jordan was like yeah
you can see me
you know see my shoe collection or
something yeah that does that's the
thing
i think celebrities are [ __ ] that up
you know yeah and it's for like
you know sex workers people who are
really trying to make some money and
make their ends meet you know i mean and
then you got these celebrities coming
like hey
this is like a patreon yeah
show us your tits yeah
[Laughter]
who's the girl that [ __ ] it up for
everybody
people were mad she didn't show anything
right um she was traditionally
no yeah she kept telling people that she
was going to show her nudes and then
never did after people
started paying for the pay-per-views
they'd pay like hundreds of dollars like
crazy amounts but then it'd be like a
photo of her in her
underwear or something yeah it really
they got their money back right
i don't think i don't know i thought the
people got their money i think only fans
was supposed to pay it because it wasn't
on her within like the terms and
agreements to give them refunds so it
fell on only fans and that's why only
fans changed their policy
got it see tyga said [ __ ] it yeah but
that's what it's for yeah
dude cycle his dick pic from like
a couple of years something that got
leaked yeah he recycled the big picture
from like
already that's right it wasn't him like
i do i need original material yeah he's
like
2009 now you're gonna pull out the 0.09
dude you want my money i need to see
some real
real-time [ __ ] what i need a monday
newspaper and your dick came
inside the photo looks like it's from
the blackberry yeah
unfair
so man rapper the rapper i know hey
yeah you're talking about a legit rapper
here son brother i'm pretty sure you
heard about rolly boy
no no i don't give a give her
give him a little subscribe to the
channel
i dropped a little shine this uh next
week and hold on can i fill him in while
you don't look a little shy
what are you talking about so his his
ex-girlfriend cheated on him with uh big
sean
wow yeah don't worry about that listen
so now
so he has some like vendetta gets big
sean damn
okay well anyways so is the dish drop is
next week
right we've been telling each other on
instagram and uh
rapper the rapper like i know you like
how you just sit down in the room and
you just write
bars yeah and stuff like that you just
like know when something is hot and it's
hot now mine is going to be hot but i
want to
test something out on you all right all
right all right look be
be real with them now this is from the
diss track let's run
okay okay okay let me get my phone right
that's why you gotta be
for us is this something no no no no
it's just two bars two bars
okay here we go you're ready i'm
embarrassed right now yeah yeah
i'm sorry i'm embarrassed now here it is
right here here this is like look
brendan told me this podcast is
ascending in the right direction harry
styles jaden brown
i feel good cause i got protection
that's a knife
i'm confused because that's a knife is
the only part
really and it's like a threat i felt
like you were bragging a little bit yeah
yeah
well you got to brag on that because you
thought okay you can say anything about
him you just said yeah there's
a podcast is ascending in the right
direction
harry styles james brown because i feel
good right
i feel good james brown yeah harry
styles right direction i was saying i
got protection
that's the knife yeah but though this is
just like i'm doing okay
like yeah big strong's like
all right i'll go back to the drawing i
think i've got to be meaner than that
bro
yeah if you want some attention you've
been rapping since what 14 you said
yeah but i my roots are in like battle
rap you know yeah
yeah i started in battle rap and then
like you know freestyling and [ __ ] and
then i started making music a little
later so i was definitely a little late
bloomer with like
making music because i was just
freestyling and battling you know i had
no interest in like making music until
like
19 20 years i feel like battle raps a
little harder right
because it's like kind of on the spot
like you that's all like subjective you
know like
making songs hard too i think you know
but
to me battling was fun because i always
grew up like roasting and [ __ ]
you know what i mean so it's like yeah i
was i was just doing that in rhyme form
when i started battling you know but i
was a class clown roasting people and i
was like young
um but battling i respect a lot of
battlers cause they put themselves
in the front line of hip-hop you know
every battle you do you're risking like
your career pretty much yeah yeah
if you get killed no one's going to
forget that no no like
and i mean we're talking about before
you came and did didn't you you almost
get in a fight
wasn't there time when it got no not so
what happened was
uh when i was battling early on all my
videos online we're getting like
millions of views just on the battles
and and you know
i met a friend who became my manager and
he was like yo all these battles are
cool you're getting millions of views
but
they're not on your channel this isn't
really your content you know he was like
we should start our own youtube channel
and i was like cool and he was like
we should think of like a viral way to
launch our youtube channel
so i like at the time when i searched
battle raps at the time on youtube all
the top battles were the ones that ended
in fights you know
because obviously like no shits are fun
to watch you know yeah so i was like yo
we should stage a fight with me
but then since i'm an asian dude like
why don't we flip it instead of just
like swinging like we do some crazy like
martial arts kick so we staged the whole
thing
i remember that yeah yeah so so the like
i'm battling this dude
which was my friend and he pushes me and
i come back and do like a roundhouse
kick and knock him out and then like the
cameras go off
and the whole day i'm like tweeting like
oh [ __ ] you won't believe what happened
the next day i get like 50 000
subscribers on youtube
that [ __ ] goes viral so it was like the
perfect like launching pass from my
youtube channel yeah
that's an og video wouldn't that come
out it came out over 10 years ago yeah i
remember it
damn so that was like the whole idea
behind the video until this day
like every time i meet somebody they're
like i gotta ask you something i'm like
was the kick real like
that's like one of the top questions
they always ask about seriously
but it's like that that that kind of
marketing especially i mean kids are
learning to do that now yeah you look at
you know just yesterday i had uh
uh this guy he's a fighter i don't know
if you're in the fight in the fight yeah
yeah i had this dylan danis guy on
and he's you know best friends with
conor mcgregor and he's looking to get a
fight with jake paul
i saw the water balloon [ __ ] right dude
yeah the water balloon [ __ ] see this
[ __ ] giant monstroid car yeah was
that right here
right literally oh my god
he's like there's connor's [ __ ] like
all right and they threw water balloons
you know water balloons oh my god and
which is what water
harmless that's whatever that's that
youtube [ __ ] through water balloons
and then uh dylan has a bad knee just
had reconstructive knee surgery so he's
trying to get better
he takes off after the truck and i'm
like oh
no don't catch up to the [ __ ] truck
please don't jump in the truck
he's trying to jump in the truck really
yeah man
but they took off wow i know he didn't
get [ __ ] up did he
no i was like how's your knee man he's
like i'm fine like god thank god you
didn't get in that truck shout out to
jake paul's driver
because he sped up dude
it would have been so many problems for
me if he would have gotten that truck
that's just wow is that what the
fighting
scene is now though no like dude yeah
the answer to
no i'm i'm wondering it seems like it's
going that direction
it's really not though like because the
ufc box is a little different but in the
ufc like it sells itself like
charles oliveira and tony ferguson two
of the best
lightweights on the planet they don't
there was no [ __ ] talking right their
talents
one guy's ranked three the other guys
ranked seven we're there to watch that
figarito and
moreno one guy's ranked uh who's the
champ the other guy's ranked number one
people are paying to see the competition
yeah in this like
weird boxing culture youtube crossover
it's kind of like literally like i'm not
mad at it like i just take myself
out of it because i'm like this is what
they it's like kind of wwe-ish
right right let's take a little break
with our boy dumbfounded because i'm
here to tell you about
lowering your student loan payments man
you gotta lower these bad boys if you're
still paying the same rate
you gotta look into it man you can
refinance
with earnest earnest can help you lower
your monthly payments
it takes just two minutes um you gotta
knock it out man quit paying that high
payment you can lower your monthly
payment i'm telling you with earnest
if you've been making the same monthly
payment on your student loans for the
last couple years
odds are you can reduce your payment and
save by refinancing
with earnest you can check your rate
it's easy it's fast to start complete a
few quick questions online
takes about two minutes then you will
get a rate estimate without affecting
your credit score
all right plus there's no uh fees
there's none of that stuff
the internet loves earnest right their
customer service is fantastic
all you gotta do is you can get a
hundred dollar cash bonus when you
refinance a student loan with
earnest.com
fighter terms conditions apply that's
100 for free when you refinance a
student loan at earnest.com
fighter terms and conditions apply once
again
three times huh once again you get a
hundred dollar cash bonus when you visit
earnest.com
fighter refinance your student loan not
available in all states
visit earnest.com for more details terms
conditions apply earnest student loan
refinance loans are made by earnest
operations llc
and mls number 1204917 california
refinancing law license
number six zero five four seven eight
eight three oh three second street suite
401 north san francisco california 94107
visit
earnest.com licenses for a full list of
licensed states
if you're still listening to this good
for you it is
earnest.com fighter getting to the gym
is tough
paying for boxing workouts boxing
classes can be expensive
you don't want to leave your house
you're working from home your kids are
at home
guess what i got you covered with fight
camp they provide
everything you need the bag the gloves
the wraps the equipment everything you
need
center your house fight camp provides
all of it boxing and kickboxing workouts
all right
you have online trainers you got an
online app you download the app you can
try it for free if you want
get all the gear sent to your house the
whole family can get in on it you can
have up to five accounts
you're working out you're getting boxing
beginners advanced
uh people know how to kick box boxing we
got you covered
great workouts from the comfort of your
home we talking about great boxing
kickboxing workouts
all right it's a great holiday gift it's
a perfect gift for anybody
who's thick trying to get in shape
trying to work out from home their
garage
their basement wherever you want to work
out fight camp allows you to do that
fight camp also allows you
to pay over time we're talking about
flexible financing as low as zero
percent apr
zero dollars down right now for limit
time holiday offer get free shipping and
a gift valued up to 109
with every fight camp package just go to
joinfightcamp.com
fighter that's right get free shipping
and a gift valued up to 109
with your first purchase bring authentic
boxing kickboxing gym right to your crib
with fight camp to get your free gift
just go to joinfightcamp.com
fighter join fightcam.com fighter
do you man like that the money out of
there part of it people
are taking it and that's why i don't
hate on it because like get yours man so
like
with dylan he could fight in bellator
against some contender in the
welterweight division which he's two and
oh and bellator he could fight in there
maybe make
i bet they pay him 20 and 20 25 so 50
grand
or he can fight jake paul get
millions and millions of eyeballs and
millions and millions of dollars
yeah so like i don't know why you
wouldn't do it unless for
jay unless for dylan it's like an ego
thing you know what i'm saying where
he's like no i won't be taken
serious i was like dude fight this dude
and then do bellator get paid get all
these uh you get that fan base then
parlay into something else oh like yeah
yeah
it makes so much sense like looking at
it from a consumer perspective like i
want to watch
crazy wwe stuff yeah like you know i
mean we just talking about with kids and
what do they have to watch they
gravitate
to like stuff that's like not like oh
this is bad he's causing trouble
i want to see that it's a tough road to
go i think there's
clearly a lane for him because you look
at how jake paul did against date rob's
like there's and people are buying it so
there's a lane
but you know i you don't want to see the
ufc
get involved like muddy the waters like
you still want the pure
sport yeah but then but i also want them
to do the thing
so i support all of it but i think you
got to be careful cross-pollination the
story leading up to the fight people are
interested in
like you versus big sean because big
sean smashed your girl
i don't know
because you'd want to fight him because
she cheated on you with big sean
people be like oh damn like i want to
see that like did you ever see
uh paulie malanagi and adrian broner it
was so great they fought over a side
piece yeah
yeah and then in the ring in the ring
paulie you get something goes
nobody talks about my side and she's
she's reading
and paulie's almost in tears i'll never
forget it nobody touched my side
that's funny like they don't there's
like certain areas of like other sports
you're like you can't do that
like you can't just be like i'm gonna go
to the nba
you know what i mean like that like you
know like i'm gonna train you really
you know really yeah you you're
saying as far as professional yeah like
like the way like these
like these guys are like i'm gonna start
boxing they start boxing and then they
go
yeah yeah yeah they can't do that with
like the nba
i like they're like you can't do that in
any way i would say though people like
what you said about how he yelled that
out like
no one says that about my sidekick but
the thing is
so people are very sensitive about their
side pieces too
that's what people get it's like oh no i
just care about my mane girl but no
people have feelings for the side pieces
and there's an ego thing when like your
side you call your side piece and she's
just like
nah i'm good i'm like doing something
else so i'm like when did that happen
you were always on call like ready to go
now you're
you know and and there's a little
animosity i know my boy who's like a
big musician dude you know what i'm
saying like he you know he's like a rock
star he has all these girls around all
the time yeah
he got like butt hurt cuz like his side
feet and like
he's like oh yeah my psych piece broke
up with me you're like
[ __ ] what'd you do for him that hurt
yeah
it's tough but to your point uh
chappelle as far as like
uh you can't do any other sport
it fighting's a little different because
it's not like
i guess they did it with cm punk but
it's like you know it's not
it takes years to be like the level of
like some of these fighters like they
can't just go and be
a ferguson you know they can't just go
out and being but they're not trying to
fight those guys
yeah i mean i guess jake's trying to
fight connor that's what i'm saying like
but in a boxing match but still that's a
little weird but
yeah but still like how but everybody to
become floyd mayweather he's not trying
to become a floyd mayweather
but like i'm saying it takes he's just
trying to fight him yeah he's just
they're trying to get paid yeah yeah
it's
easy back even for the fighter i mean
for floyd he's probably like this is
easy
well if you think about floyd like you
could fight anybody in the world but you
know logan paul has a gillian
followers on youtube yeah he's super
relevant he's gonna bring eyeballs
yeah it's you know floyd thinks it's an
easy day in the in the office just make
some money
so he's like why not people do that in
the battle rapping world
the funny thing about battle rap is like
yeah people talk [ __ ] leading up to the
battle
and then when you get in the ring it's
not fighting we talk more [ __ ] but in
rhyme
that's a always i found funny about
battle rap because
we're aggressively talking about killing
each other you know
with raps yeah you know what i'm saying
but then [ __ ] does get out of control
and people fight in the room
i saw i was watching i'm a huge fan of
worldstar i was watching
on there a few weeks ago this dude or
maybe was a woman i forget but
straight up they're fighting on there
because he brought up a a picture
of his like girl wife or mom who just
passed away
it was like clowning like they're
obituary oh yeah yeah yeah
straight up fought him yep yeah i just
feel like if you
get someone that angry to the point
where they swing at you or want to fight
you you kind of won because
you like got to them are there no rules
though are there
no you if you swing or fight in it
you're done no but but i'm not saying
like
yeah i think everything goes into battle
like the consequences you got to deal
with but i don't think you should
hold yourself back i've heard the
craziest [ __ ] like your disabled mother
like that kind of [ __ ] like
that has one arm like you know like
these are real things
i'm not even over exaggerating yeah a
dude was just clowning like you know
uh his family's disabilities like you
know your girl like pulling up got
police files and [ __ ] you know like yeah
you know it's just like but i've never
been like the research kind of battle
rapper because
to me it's like when you view it as a
viewer like
whatever on on the internet i feel like
no one why would
you care about that you know for me i
feel like i just attacked them with [ __ ]
that i can see
and everyone else can see at the same
time yeah yeah yeah yeah
high school drama yeah yeah yeah what
you was clowning a lot of people like i
watched your battles you was like more
like not the gun talking i'm more
competing yeah
yeah yeah i didn't know enough about
guns to start pulling out guys
i was like i wish i did you know shitty
shoot like
yeah if i'm gonna use gun bars i'm gonna
like spend a couple months in the range
get to know the guns yeah
just so i can use that yeah but the gun
bars is always funny to me because
people are shooting each other with like
imaginary guns on the spot and doing
that effects and [ __ ] like that yeah i
love it
yeah it's i'm a fan of it but i can't
do it because it wouldn't feel authentic
i know my [ __ ] is just
roasting you know my style was always
like not in their face but like
looking at the crowd like yo let's all
found this guy together you know what
i'm saying that was my style so everyone
has their style
is is battle rap still is it they're
still it's still a big scene
it's big it's big and it's gone very
like
the language of battle rap if you
watched it right now i feel like
you uh it's hard to understand it's so
cryptic with the bars like
like even me i watch that shot i'm like
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
i mean a lot of i mean i feel like
majority because i just kind of recently
got back into watching it
and i was like like blown away like what
are these triple entendres
yeah yeah in a while uh i haven't
battled in years
yeah oh okay in the years my last battle
was like
in canada with concussion yeah oh yeah
yeah that battle was
sponsored by drake like drake actually
paid us like he paid us to battle
like we were just like chickens in a
[ __ ] fight here's money
throwing words at each other that's all
about it he loves it yeah i mean he
wasn't making money on that battle he
just like sponsored it through money on
it
and like wasn't expecting any money back
is that on youtube yeah it is yeah yeah
it was just speaking of your battle with
conceded by the way
uh and conceded it's uh he's another
battle
he's a really good big battle rapper um
would you say that's your toughest
battle because a lot of people will say
on the comments and i was underneath
there as well
i commented to one conceited way the
only reason why
because timothy legetto de gato he was
there
and he kind of messed you up because he
was like which one am i battling
i know you can't yeah the only other
asian [ __ ]
that [ __ ] goes right in the
middle like
he's
well also i'll tell you this in battle
like he had a
huge crew behind him of like you know
new york dudes who are
really good at kind of getting that
energy up on every line
and i didn't have anybody on my end and
i [ __ ] up on that so that helps too
of course sure that that vibe just
getting to oh
yeah because the crowd is involved as
well when they hear that
yeah for sure for sure and like i to be
honest like i was already rusty because
i hadn't battled in years coming back
into this like i i'm more like
you know over 10 like 10 years ago or so
like when i was really battling you know
i got it but you you was killing them
yeah yeah where have i seen conceited
before oh wow
he's the guy who's like an outfit to cut
the beat you know
[Applause]
he had another slow it down he was like
speed it up i want to see it in real
time
that boy you talking yeah yeah yeah that
was a fun battle man honestly and they
don't see this [ __ ]
it's 22 minutes so if there's a minute
mark no what can you go through
oh yeah yeah we'll do it when you leave
yeah
yeah it is i wouldn't put my set on i'm
like we're
all going to watch my set that is true
but i'm saying it was a freestyle battle
rap it's different so that's it
he's never
that you're gonna do in uh palm beach it
would really [ __ ] you
this is years ago mm-hmm okay wait what
do you mean comparing it like how
uh like well you don't you don't want to
watch yourself oh you mean uh you see i
i don't know i think that's everyone's
preference but like me personally like i
don't i
hate watching [ __ ] back or like like
going to a spot and they're like let's
put on your song
or something i hate when they do it
it just gets me weird [ __ ] i don't know
everyone's different about it some
people are like yeah put that [ __ ] on
they won't know
over and over like you'd have to be a
raging narcissist to want to watch
yourself
yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't know it's uh
it's weird i feel like uh like with
songs
you know in the process of making it i
hear it so many times that i don't want
to hear it once it's out ever again
yeah yeah but um yeah and battles is
weird because people have different
opinions
like we could be watching it together
and you guys could be like damn he's
getting killed right now
yeah and then i'd be like oh [ __ ]
so then you transitioned and you started
working with all deaf digital correct
yeah i was on a show just i mean that
was just me
roast me yeah yeah and those
[ __ ] could roast it's like i
was like asian dude on there it was like
all right 10 black dudes and
they're beasts craig is a beast that
wrote craig is a beast crazy
but all of them are good and that's the
thing people don't realize when they
come on that show like
so we had guests from like you know the
youtube world you know fools going viral
and [ __ ]
and then they come on the show and
they'd get killed
like they get killed by the ropes you
know but were they with and were they
good roasters they were just
personalities and thought they could
hang
yeah they they just thought they could
help because you know they're roasting
with their friends
but they're in a room with like 10
comedians who are
they do this yeah and then uh what's the
show called it's called
roast me it's a good show it's really
[ __ ] funny really [ __ ] but
it i think i've seen it it's in the
majority of it's black guys
yeah yeah yeah at the desk like
a classroom and uh craig is like
probably was
yeah but i mean i got like my roots in
like roasting and all that [ __ ] was like
when i was that was
david lucas baby he's funny yeah comedy
store yeah
look at uh teddy ray teddy ready
all these dudes are good pretty good
honestly go boy boys are out there too
patrick cloud patrick kev on stage
super hilarious i went to school with a
guy who shoot the film
desi uh zach yeah yeah yeah yeah
craig will say some abstract roast stuff
oh my god
your mom your mom swims to work like
what
i don't know how that's funny your mom
swims to work i never forget when craig
told another guy he was like bro you so
frail
you let another dude name your kids
i wanted i think i'm gonna call him
charles no his name is damian brother
that's [ __ ] nice
craig was getting everybody with one
roast at a time like
straight in a row and he pointed at me
he was like your mom killed a black dude
in the riots
yeah you're from here yeah i'm in
koreatown yeah my whole life
shut up yeah but like my i got into
rapping in high school and
the big thing that changed for me was i
was going to an open mic in south
central
in limerick park and that was like uh
a lot of og like rappers and some of the
best freestyles come out of this open
mic it's like the comedy store but for
like rabbits
yeah yeah and like i even like craig's
from there too he used to rap and stuff
but oh yeah
but that place was like the place that
like honed my [ __ ] like roasting
battling freestyling just like any of
the sharpening comedy yeah
any comedy spot that you guys is it
still popping over there
no it's not i feel like open mics just
are kind of dead you know what i'm
saying
everything's kind of shifted online yeah
you know i mean not for comedy comedy
you still have the you know the places
to go but
for music there isn't many of those
spots
yeah and people just put it up on
youtube or something
[ __ ] now yeah kids aren't like trying to
like hone their [ __ ] through
open mics they just want to like get
their [ __ ] out they want views
they want views they want listeners they
want a manager
yeah right like right away yeah it's
interesting too because now there's so
many forms
of like media for people to get all
their [ __ ] out yeah like think how many
different
avenues are to get your [ __ ] out now i'm
not even mad at that and them for that
because
they do get really good too because
there's so much information out there
you know what i'm saying as an artist or
comedian right you can like
now young kids could go online and find
information
on news and what's going on so easily
like
growing up you'd have to kind of go out
and experience that
you can't and that was the only way
wikipedia it you know what i'm saying
so but now they have references too like
oh this dude did it this way
digitally going on youtube i can do it
all
pull up old bits you know and be like
okay i i got the blueprint
yeah you know there's no blueprint back
then really no you just [ __ ]
had to go just throw yourself yeah go
and do it
yeah yeah so yeah that's where it's at i
mean venues now
all around are just kind of dying in
general
you know because of covid right right
right right so i mean
are you saying before covet or like no i
mean no i mean because
especially i feel like people have that
conversation right you guys are in
comedy
so about if comedy is going to ever be
in the same place again like how do you
all feel about is that gonna
bounce back it'll about but i think if
you just stayed in l.a
you're like damn comedy's [ __ ] or
music's [ __ ] if you get out like we've
been touring this entire
thing oh really yeah you get out of la
you're like oh we're gonna be fine
yeah texas is lit nashville phoenix
texas will laugh at you if you're
wearing a mask
look at this yeah yeah seriously yeah
but i think that if more people got out
of
la because you don't realize how bad it
is here like dylan dannis flew in from
he lives in manhattan
i was like dog how's manhattan locked
down is it terrible he's like way better
than hair
he's like you guys are [ __ ] locked
down
like you don't realize dude get out yeah
you don't yeah you never realize until
you get out
like and it's so funny because yeah we
here we walk around with masks on but
like
other places like i'll go and i'll put
my mask on it's it's like
the [ __ ] are you doing yeah you know
what i mean restaurants are popping yeah
obviously the comedy clubs are packed
yeah that's crazy
it is strange man it is going back to
battle rap real quick
and i'm gonna get off it yeah i don't
research i watch a lot of battle rap
and battle rap etiquette i noticed when
like say your opponent
say like a fire bar and the crowd go
crazy
to your reaction y'all just drink water
is that like a salute like i see you
or what is that i think it's just like
something to do
yeah i see like some battles and
every everyone's like yo where's my
where's my like
take a sip every two like i'm already
doing it right now because i'm coming
from battle rappers
i'm getting dry after every two lines
but i don't know what it is yeah it's
just i feel like it's weird to just
stand there
while your opponent is hitting you the
crowd is going crazy i do always say
this and battle rap is interesting
because it's kind of like comedy and a
heckler but the heckler gets a chance at
you too
correct and the heckler's pretty
talented too yeah exactly
it's very rare with a heckler has
something creative for sure
it's like echo's not just some drunk
dude you could overpower afterwards he's
gonna have a mic too
yeah and he's a comedian yeah so that's
always interesting
and and it's a lot of work for like
something you can't really recycle over
again two if you prepare for a battle
right
and you use it in a video you're never
gonna use that again
you can't like that's the medium you
can't do it like in comedy you could
actually you know go to the next city
you know i would say that's why i do
give battle rap a lot of respect and i
say that not
you know to the battlers now because i'm
not really battling right now you know
but
it's a lot of prep that you can only
use once it's like that nut you can only
bust it once and that's it you know and
are they making money off that like
you're like yeah yeah
yeah it's it's a it's a i mean it still
gets tons of views
it is a scene it's a subculture that
exists so but
so they're making money off the youtube
revenue uh no
these leak there's like leagues right
like mba but it's like url
ultimate rap and like when you
partake in that and there's these
there's top tier middle tier bottom tier
of battle rappers and they get paid
to battle to compete that to compete
yeah
yeah and i don't know what the rates are
and [ __ ] but you know enough where these
people
just battle rap oh damn that's dope
there's battle rappers who have no
interest in making music they're just
like i'm a battle rapper
because they're getting a lot of money
you know mook just made 20 mil i mean
i'm saying i'm sorry i'm so sorry
20 000 uh versus jesus
that's a complete mishap
yeah i mean there's some money in it
like someone like top tier you can get
paid like fifty thousand dollars for a
battle
yeah i think i think so and who who's
like the top few
like is there a guy who's like yeah the
head over heels better than everybody
else yeah he's like the face of it
hey man you're still renting those dirty
ass scooters right around town
if you are you're gross you need to
check out unagi it's incredible it's
total electric
super portable you can bring it in to
the freaking restaurant you're going to
the bars
a quick push of the button and it's
breaking down for you man it's an
electric carpet under your feet
all right no more ubers no more subways
use this especially at nyc
it's made of carbon fiber folds with one
freaking click man
and it's uh 26 pounds you have 15 miles
of range it has amazing power all right
it is my favorite scooter ever it looks
dope
and i got a incredible deal for you guys
all right all you got to do to get 200
off uh the best electric scooter on the
planet you're gonna go to unagi scooters
dot com slash fighter that's u
n a g i scooters.com
fighter they're only doing 500 of these
all right so it's first come first serve
so get yourself the best electric
scooter and ride free
that's unagi scooters.com
fighter listen man the holiday season is
a coming
and you're scrambling for meals you
don't know what you're gonna do
you those maybe the store you're going
to is closed you know what to do so
guess what i got you covered man
i got you covered with omaha steaks they
got their holiday feast it's delicious
omaha steak butchers cut flaming youngs
come in this thing
you're talking about perfectly aged hand
carved famously tender all right
all also including the package are tons
of incredible meats for your mouth
amazing sides and of course the omaha
steaks
desserts and right now you can get this
mouth-watering package plus
four free burgers and a free digital
meat thermometer
to measure your meat for an exclusive
price only available to you
t-fat kz listeners go to omahasteaks.com
enter the code fighter into the search
bar that's extra burgers plus an extra
gift
that's on the list of any serious
griller all right so go
check out omaha steaks we're talking
about quality guaranteed
all right safety with every order omaha
steaks is fifth generation
family owned company with over 100 years
of doing this
delicious meat for your mouth every oma
steak orders flash frozen vacuum sealed
safely delivered in a cooler with dry
ice that means fresher
than fresh visit omahastakes.com type
fighter in the search bar to shop
gourmet grill packs today
this is a great opportunity to get ahead
of the holiday gift shopping and have a
really fun
season enjoy and and who who's like the
top few
like is there a guy who's like yeah the
head over heels better than everybody
else
yeah he's like the face of it yeah right
well right now they was pumping i don't
know if he was in a bigger url so url is
like the nba
right that's the league that's the least
king of the dots
they're both the two biggest you know
what i mean what would you say like
king of the dad is like if you play
overseas is it like ufc bellator
because is it like because canada yeah
yeah
it's interesting it's like ufc bellator
maybe yeah it's kind of like that like
it's not big
but ufc is the main yeah yeah it's not
they're both big they're both big it's
just different styles
you know a little bit there's a
different kind of uh crowd for it it's
like
wwe and like wcw something like that
yeah
they're both doing well they're both
doing well but it's a different one
might have more stars
yes maybe yeah i don't know i can't
speak on it i don't really it's like a
preference kind of thing i get what you
say nice because you know him listen url
uh uh who's that who's the face of url i
will say
now correct me if i'm wrong i don't know
is it does it stand for underground
no no uh ultimate rap league oh ultimate
rap oh wow
yeah so it's like
the battles that he would throw when i
was like in high school
yeah be pre youtube like he would have
videos up online
before youtube that's cool yeah so i i
got to show him his like response
did you were you mad wait but so who's
the uh
the number one guy right now in my
opinion i'll probably get like
slack but uh romnetty romney is the guy
who
has like so like he said like he is just
like different layers
he's he's famous in that space he's
families in that space but a lot of
people say him murder mook
yeah it's so it's uh it's so many stars
murder mook
murder mook yeah that's the guy he's an
og mook is an og like i would watch his
battles when i was younger yeah you know
i'm sorry
he's still doing it yeah but that's me
you got to age out a little bit right
like i don't want to see [ __ ]
ti rapping at 75 you know battle rap is
different though
because it's not like if you're a rapper
in the music industry
you're trying to sell cool right yeah
and obviously younger generation
is cooler yeah but in battle rap it's
just really all about the bars
you can come in you know come into the
match with a walker and like
so if your bars are there then you're
good you know what i'm saying
um that's cool but the industry you know
the music industry is all youth driven
so you got to look forward it's all
about loans
uh they even do like uh teammates
tag two and twos two on two they're fine
do you like those better dna dna
i don't know if i like it better but it
is a different vibe i used to do the two
on twos too and they're they're fun
because you get a chance to kind of
chill for a little bit while your
partner goes at them for a bit like rest
a little bit
let me ask you how how long is a battle
wrap typically
like in that league how long it's long
some of the rounds they go
are each round could be like five
minutes plus
that's insane it is that's what i'm
saying it's like
think about like you have a whole hour
set of material
and you just you could only use it once
you know that's
not yeah and more the partners that's
why it's easier with a partner now was
your partner no disrespect korean
no no no he was black oh okay yeah it's
hard to find another asian battle rapper
yeah because you were only asian
before me it was like jen jin which is
from rough riders and then it was me
and then there's been nobody like
there's been no no youngsters coming up
oh wait i can't i mean not that i know
of like i would have known about him i
mean obviously it's completely dominated
by black dudes is there a few
is this sprinkled and some white boys in
there no there's some white boys
there is a lot of white boys there's a
lot of black dudes um there's latinos
asians there are not many asians i
wonder why
i don't have bars brenden well i bet you
they do they're just i don't know maybe
they're focused on k-pop or some [ __ ]
i don't know they're probably there's an
asian rappers in the music industry
but they're not they're not in the
battle rap scene they're probably like
i don't know if this is like lucrative
they're trying to like bank bro
like if you're like their parents will
kill them for being a rapper if you
battle rapper you're disowned yeah
you're just like what is the point of
this
like um it was like that no no no i
don't know about that but i'm just
i don't know what it is it just doesn't
i took it seriously
i'm surprised i would think there's i
mean they're probably the pie is and
maybe i'm not on the pulse about it or
something but
but nothing that sticks out no no i wish
they'll be it'd be nice to have like
some representation in the
battle rap side a little bit what do you
ever think about like you watch a battle
now could you just say you're getting
back into it you was like
man i could take him do you ever like
all the time that's like that that'll
never leave my head like i still think
in battle raps
like i could be in like a board meeting
and like i
just start battling the guy who's like
just like when i hold my tongue like i
got battles going on in my head and
afterwards i'm like pleasure meeting you
it's like my way of like just talking
[ __ ] and venting and [ __ ]
but so you're gonna get back into battle
rap you think no no
no i mean you know i i always never say
tickled by the
the idea yeah they're getting paid
they're getting paid man yeah it's fun
but
i will admit like i don't act like oh i
i'm just ready to just jump back in
these dudes are have evolved yeah you're
not gonna disrespect the game
yeah yeah i'm not of course not hell no
it's like anything else right you just
yeah it's like me like i'll i'll fight
stephen like [ __ ] you've been telling
me
for seven years it's easy for artists to
just
leave at the top and just feel like oh
that's where they're
they're frozen in time you know what i'm
saying but nah
[ __ ] is the game's evolving i respect it
you know yeah and so now you're doing
oh go ahead so now you're doing
podcasting
yeah podcasting that's where rappers go
to die you know what i'm saying
or or to make money and knowing all
their [ __ ] yeah yeah no i love
podcasting because i always feel like
even
when i first started rapping like i was
into just conversing and you know
having dialogue with people but i also
act and i write
like the scripts and [ __ ] like that okay
oh yeah yeah so i do a lot of you pretty
active yeah i try to be on my like asian
donald glover [ __ ]
there you
your podcast called what it's called fun
with dumb oh that's dope
yeah it's it's the same vibe you know
what i'm saying same thing mike's
falling off
oh yeah yeah it's the same vibe as this
yeah it's just no prep just
yeah it's just riffing yeah yeah yeah
yeah like
we don't do prep here yes if you watch
tv you know right yeah
hold on we had he they're also he's new
to the game
yeah yeah well hold on you watch tv
that's a great question all right all
right
you got to start the course you like
like you enjoy water and chairs
i've been doing this eight years man i
saw you thinking it looks like you enjoy
water uh
hey man so you like you are those jeans
comfy
so you got little holes in them you like
i do hate sometimes how like
unprepared i am sometimes when i have a
guest okay or something come through
because i mean i like as much as i like
riffing and kind of letting the
conversation go sometimes i like
[ __ ] i probably should have prepared
yeah so you got everybody like that
y'all
feel like that yeah sometimes i have a
guest co-host but
usually um i mean most of the time if
it's like co-hosts we just have like a
round table just
riff yeah yeah but then when i have like
a new guest it's just me and the person
you know it's very intimate it's very
like it is it is and there's times like
it's the lesson you you get better and
better at interviewing and sometimes
you'll get stuck
yeah yeah you want some red vines
you was great last episode i'm not
eating them i'm just offering them
are they fresh or whatever yeah they are
fresh yeah they stay fresh i'm just on a
diet
and i keep looking at it weird man he's
in the middle of history
what transition podcast mistake i
apologize dude
that's what kind of transition the whole
[ __ ] thing is that was a strange
transition i was trying to see the
segway
speaking of red vines my stomach's
growling so
hey but yeah so i love how you know your
transition from battle rap
then you say you're writing you're doing
your donald glover so like what's next
i feel like everything that i do is
gonna
um i mean my first projects when i write
and do stuff for tv and film
it's gonna reflect all my experiences
like personally you know i'm
not going to like write game of thrones
or some [ __ ] you know yeah
i always feel like that's kind of always
a transition so there's a lot of stuff
based off of like
my personal life as like aging in the
rap game
you know battle rap and things like that
are the themes of like
projects that i'm working on you know
what i mean and i i find that
interesting because like being mid 30s
in the rap game is interesting because
that's like being 50 in the rap game
yeah yeah
and rap years you know i mean so i i
talk a lot about that in the show i'm
working on right now based on my life
and
talking about like oh yeah how does how
do you deal with that
when you're a working class rapper
because every time when you think about
like a rapper you think about
this grand you're on a yacht popping
champagne
yeah but you don't think about it as
like a regular gigging
yeah in color really rappers so i think
that's
kind of what i'm exploring in that show
yeah yeah that sounds really dope
yeah and like dealing with how you how
do you deal with that of being like
uh maybe you were more hot back then and
like now maybe less
yeah the ego do you have a family too
you have kids uh no i don't but i have
like you know it's interesting with my
family like dealing with that too
because like it's harder to explain to
your asian parents like
how successful you are when they don't
see like that's where i was going with
it yeah you don't see a billboard or you
don't see like
me on the korean newspaper yeah you're
not watching red carpets and [ __ ] yeah
whatever
they got newspapers yeah we got
newspapers we watch tv too
but also i think it's interesting what
else is there
too is if you know to your narrative of
you being that you know 30 something
rapper
and your your korean family not
realizing like
what your goals and dreams are because
you can't you're not pulling up in a
bentley or something
exactly but then also i think for a
rapper it's like they release like
bad example but let's say like gucci
mane or something
release the hot track and then he has
kids too so it's like this weird dynamic
they gotta
[ __ ] with you know yeah feels like
you're a dad but then in your
your lyrics and your rap it's this
completely different lifestyle
it is they're going home to your kids
it's like being a kid and just getting
into all this [ __ ] [ __ ] and being like
[ __ ] the cops and now i'm like i pay my
parking tickets on time you know what
i'm saying yeah
i guess i'm mad it's like i don't give a
[ __ ]
i'm like now i kind of do give a [ __ ]
you know i was like 401k
and it's about thinking about those
things you know and it's like feels
weird because like my mom's still like
my biggest fan and like will gas me up
and be like yeah my son's like big as
jay-z i'm like no i'm not dead
so like those dynamics are very
interesting and i put a lot of that into
the show
right like the comedy of that yeah you
want to keep it at a comedic tone
correct it is it's comedic but it's like
dark comedy if you really think about it
yes
which is which is like like a lot of
router like a lot of comedies are like
taken to like
the satire yeah it's idea of like okay
like i've been dumbfounded more than
i've been john park
most of my life at this point you know
like how do i
like if i'm not dumbfounded who am i
like
i'm john park and i feel regular as [ __ ]
you know what i mean
like and dealing with that right now in
my mid 30s is like a real thing to me
and i think it'd be even weirder if if
you had kids right like trying to
explain to your kids why
fans come up calling you dumb exactly
what i'm saying like
i'll like i'll go to the mall with my
son and people will come up to me and
he's like dad how do you know them
daddy that's your friend i'm like those
are not my friends
yeah but then why are they coming up to
you right explain it to them
right very strange man it is it is a
strange thing but it's great
i find i'm finding a lot of humor in it
you know what i'm saying and like it's
great material for like
what i'm trying to do next it's just
like life reflecting art
you know and vice versa yeah man it's
dope it's crazy
it's really dope yeah i think like with
the rap game too it's interesting like
uh donald glover did it good because he
like his friend was the rapper right and
it kind of shows you the hustle he went
through like
trying to get his record play or you
know his his feature played on
on the radio stage stuff like that and
like now when it comes to radio stations
there
you know race stations are cool and
there's still there's still an avenue
for a radio station like 105 9 here is
big right right
power but also you don't really need
that like that avenue is kind of dead
dude right
like sound cloud now like takashi 6'9
you know obviously
i'm sure you have your opinions on but
like he's not played on the radio
he's [ __ ] huge dude you know how much
money those kids make i mean all the
all the podcasts like this and all the
independent podcasts are like a
testimonial to that
yeah you know the numbers are stupid
yeah and like the fans aren't driven
towards you know they don't care if
you're on iheartradio or
serious like they want you to own your
[ __ ] and they want you to
they just want you to put it out they
don't care that you're with some big
you know corporate actually it almost
turns them off of it
right right right right i mean that's
i'm navigating through that i've always
been independent though because it's
like
people are always like how come you
never signed and i'm like
because no one offered me a deal
we love you man you stay independent
like no i would definitely sign it if i
could
i talk about like a lot of the
backhanded compliments sometimes fans
give you because you'll have a fan come
up to you and be like
um bro like i'm your biggest fan
you still rapping i'm like yes
[ __ ]
i just dropped the project actually and
it's like cats don't know
they're doing that a little bit you know
what i mean it'll hurt your feelings
dude i'm the [ __ ] dude i'm the biggest
fan dude when's your next fight i'm like
really are you [ __ ] me seven years
ago dude are you
right right they did the same [ __ ] about
the battle [ __ ] yeah like when's your
last bat when's your next battle i'm
like i haven't battled in six years
and it's hard not to be like are you
[ __ ] serious dude like
next fight yeah that's insane when did
you let yeah when's your next battle
wrap you're like
my favorite [ __ ] was when somebody was
like yo i'm your biggest fan
dumbfounder like got my name i got my
name wrong
they always say biggest fan yeah yeah
for sure for sure
i'm like dude y'all throw that around
too loose yeah yeah yeah
biggest fan little too loose or someone
to take a picture and another person
come over and be like
i should i know who you are can i get a
picture i'm like i know
i i hate that feeling oh yeah
like who are you like oh it's the worst
dude
it's like just know that you're going to
know some people you're not going to
know some people like what they're
playing yeah just please don't do this
yeah man yeah that was that was great um
before we get into that that was great
no i was out of edge gym before it gets
more awkward
i want the battle rapper oh [ __ ] why you
gotta do my boy like
because i'm all right i'm rusty too bro
well hold on bro i wrote all two days
for this battle
and i'm gonna oh you you prepared for
two days again two days dumb over here
it gets done because he didn't rap in
six years
i mean it's all my battle around yeah
yeah yeah all right and i wrote i want
these he's
a professional i get it but he's rusty
i am rusty so this would be the time to
just get thank you
i did my research he already drinking
water i already know he's mouth dry i'm
ready but don't start off with like
i got a successful podcast
that's for big sean don't do that don't
do that oh you got new bars i got new
boards
all right do you want to flip a coin or
how you want just the real do you
do and let me but first do you really
want to do this dumbfounded uh whatever
i mean
uh it's just for fun i want to see light
as that's all right that's what i want
yeah put up the coin this is fantastic
you want to go first i'll go oh i got a
coin
we're doing it really we're doing a real
thing yeah i i dreamed i've never really
seen a battle wrap before
my friend here we go all right hands and
[ __ ] heads hands and bits
tails uh you go first
oh
just for fun don't worry just watch this
all right here we go i can't wait for
this
yeah and there's no beats right nope
let's just go
i said joe i'm sitting on the couch with
you
oh no but i ain't trying to doubt you um
i'm outside bro underneath the guns
but i got ones in my pocket stop it i
got a rocket you can see me but i'm john
horton
stop starting i got a cooler kit slow
like molasses
asses i skipped classes hallway passes
check this out dawg
korean korean korean korean asian
mista i saw that plane it was malaysian
i got girls persuasion boy come on man
these bars is hitting
stop whipping big sean little kind de
don papa john's i don't care i'm not
quitting
dumbfounded get grounded get on this
floor and i start mounting
you on top don't stop i call the cops
you do i get the parking ticket
john parks
my government name
stop trying to battle at me yeah you
look like you just came from a maga
rally
it's my turn you're next how you gonna
wear dirty cortez with a rolex
you're like little j little sean
you you got your girl smashed by big
sean
i feel bad for you all right i'm gonna
do it oh [ __ ] i'm done
i won that round i won that round no i
choked i
choked
cortez with the rolling it was fantastic
sad just for fun
guys i'm not rusty man i'm rusty you
know oh well it's good though i
appreciate you
i appreciate it i was impressed thank
you thank you
i mean even dumb had the greatest
[ __ ] yeah
i get on top and i start mounting you on
top call the cops i pay your parking
ticket john parks no weekends
that was written i thought you were
freestyling oh
nothing really went over the head like
it was pretty straightforward
like we got
it was a pretty straightforward bar
all right all right i
yeah that was interesting is that the
first battle rap we had on you
uh let me look yup
yeah no i can't believe that serious
question
what i was like no we've actually had
quite a few yeah yeah we have quite a
few
i have to point out though malik you
said you haven't mounted but then he's
on top
no i said i'm on top no you said he's on
top he's on top
you said i'm mounted yeah but he's only
got to stop
we
[Applause]
that's the west
oh
no girls allowed man
i hate that had to be my last battle
i'm sorry last battle i've ever done
a fighter in the kids it gets really
good now when they put dumbfounded last
battle on youtube that is gonna come
up people like what your mom's gonna
look at this
i gotta explain this she's bragging to
her friends like oh he's a big battle
rapper
he's on his little red couch
that was great okay so tom cruise is
currently filming in
mission impossible seven and there has
been a recording that got leaked where
he's yelling at two crewmates for
breaking
covet protocol it's like two to three
minutes
does anyone have a problem with it
though not making movies right now
because of us
because they believe in us
you got the mission impossible mask too
that one is
we are creating thousands of jobs
you [ __ ] damn i don't ever want
to see it again
ever what crew member was like yep no
doubt and just hit me just start
recording keep going
what was happening they were like two
group members making out
so i uh watched it on the news this
morning
it was two crew members in mask but they
were looking at a screen
so they're like what and you just went
the [ __ ] off are you serious
what was it so it was a six feet thing
yeah that they weren't six feet apart
but they had mask on and they were like
you know looking at
like a movie set they were [ __ ]
looking back and like you know playing
back the playback yeah
he like went off you can tell he's under
a ton of pressure
you know because he thinks you know
because if their movie gets stopped
because of kobe the whole
movie is just as [ __ ] up so he's under
a little pressure but also it's like
man he's talking about firing people
both sides like
he's overboard but i get it oh yeah yeah
he's overboard uh so don't get it i i'd
like [ __ ]
none of us could be here if we didn't
get tested so we know for a fact yeah
nobody has it and also you're a
scientologist no no one is wearing masks
at the scientology church
like ron hubbard got us right there
he's like what are you talking about
dude that's a good point
[Music]
okay you guys talked about this but the
footage of jake paul pulling up on you
guys during
uh food truck diaries is viral i mean i
can't get a tag in this [ __ ]
i was looking for you the whole time so
what are you doing i'm in a black hoodie
i'm right next to him i'm right
there right there
[ __ ] wow i stepped out of the way i
don't want to get hit with [ __ ]
he called that man a [ __ ] and throwing
water balloons
shout out to the driver i will
say though you know i wish that they
threw
eggs or something like if it was more
disrespectful like it would be something
more
yeah like eggs would be disrespectful
you might have to kill somebody
you know what i was worried about yeah
but maybe they were a little bit more
respectful
for you and just i think they knew a lot
of balloons is pretty tame
yeah i'm saying but the the funny thing
is is they had
um toilet paper soaked in water which i
thought was kind of brilliant
and that's what hit dealing dance right
in the face oh wow
you've seen jake paul's uh yeah jake
paul changed his profile
wait what i would say the aim was pretty
good
i'm trying to nervous wait what what
happened
i'm telling you those boys you know
they're very glad that dylan didn't jump
in there oh no no yeah
he's twisting necks and snapping oh
wow how about jake paul follows two
people conor mcgregor's wife
and who else and uh dylan dennis's
girlfriend
no trolling mm-hmm and then uh
dylan danis changed his ig profile photo
to
a photo of him and jake's ex-girlfriend
who he fake married on youtube
tana mojo okay okay dylan oh sh
well they're not [ __ ] around she's
kind of hot
she has only fans apparently she makes
millions off of it there you go
oh yeah naturally scroll out chin what's
his
what do you post about it oh that third
picture the first one here yeah
should i kill this [ __ ] this is two
weeks ago yeah november 20. so are they
supposed to fight or what's the beef
here i don't
really i think you want connor but oh
okay but that's conor's buddy
so maybe that's why who's that who's
that she's like
that's like an influencer girl that's
his girl yeah
but you'll never see her you just see oh
no you see her oh okay she has like a
she i think she's super bad yeah
her thing's bigger than his i think
she's
attractive yeah that's his girl shout
out
can't be mad at that can't be mad at
that at all salute uh
champ dylan yeah dylan's interesting one
too
because uh come to daddy i see you
dylan's interesting because he uh you
know he plays this
persona like he talks about [ __ ] he's
like a really nice person oh he's like a
good dude love a good nice person
yeah it's like yeah that's what's weird
you know like and i want him on the show
for that reason
to show his like character yeah but then
when jake paul pulled up
and then he was just like pissed was he
mad furious after that [ __ ] he wanted to
[ __ ] him
like he was like oh uh he was like my
boy went to his house party i don't know
where he [ __ ] lives
he's i should go up there i'm like
please don't dude oh damn
yeah like he was so upset so although it
was a viral moment
whatever it also i don't say it [ __ ]
up the interview but it made him like
you know super like aggro because he had
to finish the food truck
dude that happened the first 10 minutes
of talking would y'all eat churros
that's a happy fool you can't get mad at
the churros yeah but after that he was
like dude he wanted to [ __ ]
kill somebody after the churros before
the churros
yeah oh yeah that's true that's true
especially el pollo loco but he's a good
dude man
that's kind of cool it's viral back in
oh man okay so pornhub just purged all
of its unverified content
so before the purge there was 13.5
million videos on
pornhub and then after they took out all
unverified footage
there was only 4.7 million videos so
like
all the amateur shit's gone anything
that isn't from
their uh like some sort of like verified
user it's kind of like only fans where
you write on a piece of paper
with a photo of your face like i am blah
blah blah i give consent to being in
this video posting it
or if you're a part of their model
program like secure and stuff
and so they took down all of that
because uh i'll secure stuff
no no also akira is a part of their
model program so her stuff can stay on
because she's verified
um they took it down because there were
i believe 118 videos
of miners having sex on pornhub that
they found
and so pornhub went out of their way to
take down all unverified posts to kind
of review it and make sure everything's
good
and mastercard and visa said that
they're no longer going to allow
payments from their credit cards go
through to pornhub oh wow
and so a lot of companies are now how
many hours of footage was removed
like i don't know how much hours but it
was more than half of their
calories what did they do
84 million instances of child sexual
abuse was that that's correct
on facebook 118.
what facebook can i do nothing dude
facebook is a piece
of right lot of people are giving
pornhub a lot of [ __ ] because they
specialize in adult content but they are
pointing out that facebook has so much
more
and aren't doing anything about it
that's [ __ ] wild awful are you guys
on facebook i deleted my facebook no
same i know i'm on it because i got
family i haven't i've been on facebook
in
15 years i've got a fan's account on
there my brother runs it but i don't
i got tired of all like certain cats i
grew up with posting conspiracy [ __ ] on
the phone
yeah it's just that's what made me like
you know pull the trigger on just like
yeah that's just like yeah because they
get so gassed up when they get like a
like
on their status update or something like
from people they're just like oh yeah
i'm
three likes man
being sued by 22 of the women wait
pornhub is being sued dude [ __ ]
pornography
they work for a while facebook dude huge
issue yeah
i know that facebook [ __ ] is crazy um
yeah i didn't know they could put porn
on facebook so uh
on facebook it's one of those things
where you can kind of post whatever you
want and unless somebody catches it or
flags it it kind of stays up
jesus facebook is such a large platform
that it's hard for them to have a team
large enough to filter everything out
because they they they put porn on
twitter too yeah
twitter and you can put it i always i i
always wondered how they regulate porn
like twitter is crazy because you can
just go to this timeline there's like
political [ __ ] all of a sudden there's
like some [ __ ] going on
yeah you're like straight up it is too
early to be horny right now
it is 2 p.m i'm running errands and
there's like a below job going on
i think on twitter videos with the porn
the limit is two minutes and 20 seconds
that's very specific that's a long time
yeah it is how do you know that
i did my research again malik news
report
facebook it's unlimited so it is kind of
some kind of restriction on twitter
as far as like it give you a limit
towards your video your porn
what's weird is even if you let's say
they take off facebook they take off
twitter
they're taking off pornhub it just goes
to the dark web or reddit like reddit
doesn't regulate anything
yeah like there's a awful [ __ ] on there
dude i'm so sorry but we just mentioned
reddit a lot
what is that i'm so sorry for mine it's
like a form
yeah it's kind of like a blog form that
people use to kind of talk to each other
about certain topics
very cataloged i would say um i don't
i've never really gotten into that
reddit world but i know it's a whole
nother
i've never done i just know like there's
dark [ __ ] on there okay
like child porns that like horrible [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
it's weird they don't regulate that [ __ ]
yeah and who runs these like who who's
the ceo of reddit
uh one of the founders was serena
williams uh husband
but he backed down that was the dude who
left the company right
and gave his spot he said he wanted to
give a spot to a woman all right
wow yeah wow so he's not associated with
it anymore
that's crazy alexis honey or something
like that right oh hannah
yeah something like that yeah man reddit
just did it
the bar is no stop under
and then this is malik's oh yeah
is that your girl no that that's one
that's janae aiko anyways
halloween you everyone know and all the
fans know i dressed up as you know
that mailman and not my i had a
significant
and significant um
so either way the guy sees my story
everybody tags them and stuff like that
dum-dum decided to shoot a video called
body language
and dresses up as my my my hollywood
so you think it's it's referencing your
halloween because he knows that he knows
that this is gonna drop next week so he
put this video out
seven days before me and and it's going
up so is this a
highly anticipated diss track that's
dropping yeah everyone's tagging
are you serious yeah wow i didn't know
this was like a real beef that's like
brewing
i don't think it is i don't think i
don't think he knows
anything well people are tagging him
right right right you should go down you
probably see my tag it's a couple of but
this is her this is her page but don't
worry about it
you see like a couple of malik bees and
stuff all right all right there you go i
haven't seen any
because this is her page though right
it's her picture yeah so who's got a big
sean
story's different oh no he didn't even
post it huh but he knows
but either way me and my queen we
dressed up as you know poetic justice
and we we did a little post and then
look at this guy okay
you know there you go can we show oh
she's she's
playing janet jackson yeah that's why
she's drunk can we show
the uniform because don't find it kind
of confused
what about it i said i said to the cat i
sent the cat
oh you kind of look it's not all you're
like big sean
don't say no is that a thing i'm not
trying to offend you but you know
no
[Music]
to my store yeah i'll post it on the
store on your storage yeah
all right this one right here by the way
cat's out mount right now yeah spotify
itunes look how legit that uniform is
look at that
yeah you stole it from somebody you all
look alike
yeah they do look they really do wow now
going to click to the next slide
wait wait wait and the backwards hat
that's the thing
he's copying me he's copying me exact
angle
there's some there's some i feel like
i'm starting to become a believer in
this conspiracy right here that you're
pointing out low-key
you see it now because the the mailman
outfit looks very similar to each
other's
thank you but it's a famous character
yeah what a justice but
if you listen to this song body language
it has nothing to do with poetic justice
that's all i'm saying okay you can now
you we know how big
there's a lot of music videos that don't
have nothing to do with the song but why
would he do lucky lucky that's that
movie is 30 years old
why not it's nostalgic what are you
talking about i didn't no one did it
this year but me
yeah that's a fair point but now it's a
serious too yes
nobody talk about my side chick like
i'm not i'm not a huge conspiracy guy
but he's kind of selling me on this roll
right here so listen here's how it
starts
hey listen it's blowing up you gotta be
my gateway into conspiracy
right yeah he's talking about vaccines
here we go jfk though that that one's
kind of
that one's been around for a minute that
was yeah that was pretty legit i feel
like this is no longer a conspiracy it's
just like
that's what happened that's the og of
conspiracies right there
brendan sold me on that one yeah but if
we did the tour
all right this first one's a little sad
okay oh no
charlie pride who was probably one of
the most i think one of the very first
yeah african-american country stars
passed away
that's terrible well they say
african-american in the article so i
want to make sure [ __ ]
for the first black uh you know country
star
yeah in the article it actually does
what i highlighted what i highlighted oh
yeah this first african-american
superstar there you go
listen no disrespect i've never heard of
him have you
hold on i i i haven't either to be
honest hold on you'll never
give me a song and i'm like
[Music]
the only person who really listens to
country is chin though yeah i don't know
i feel like i grew up listening to in
texas i remember
but old country like the origins are
from black people
yeah i mean music yeah exactly so it's
it's really wild when you think about
like country now yeah
it's completely different
xanax he made 20 million wait oh no i'm
just kidding
20 grand i don't understand the whole
vibe of like
people you know people who like love hip
hop right now
like country was always kind of hated on
like everyone's like i listen to
everything except country yeah that's me
i'm like country but it's not that hard
to listen to you know what i'm saying
like it doesn't it's deep in those
countries yeah
some of them country country now is a
little more pop though right
like there's a lot of more pop though i
just never had like a problem like
listen to it
you know what i'm saying to be like i
listen to everything except for country
like really you listen to everything
i don't know if those rules are
listening like metal and [ __ ] you know
they always say like i don't listen to
country your country's so but now it's
now it's big yes yeah it's
i don't know i mean if someone gave me
like something to like really get into
it
i don't know send me something songs
yeah what what
did you love you was like was kissing
all those girls and he said i'm gonna go
morgan wallin
oh morgan he's great too is that a good
yeah his stuff is good yeah yeah
yeah he's more hip like current
but he has an old feel so that's why
it's like he's probably the best person
to start off with
so you so i should start in the modern
or should i go back oh i wouldn't go
back
no once you enjoy the modern like his
style you'll enjoy the
past don't go back oh yeah go back there
you go tim mcgraw
because it's real boring and racist no
not that far
is there a lot of racist like old
country joints or what
i'm guessing they're thinking like old
school with that's not recorded kind of
country
right right yeah back in like alabama
yeah i mean i don't know i'll give it
i'll give it another shot but like i
mean i'll send you a playlist of like
good country music if you want remember
i remember nelly tried to get hip-hop
fans in the country with that song with
tim mcgregor
his song with kane brown's huge but when
he did it with tim mcgraw that's when
they were both at their peaks yeah yeah
so that's why i was like it's super
influential but
no one's bigger than kane brown right
now in the country he's hey brown's
killing him
and nellie did a song with him it's
pretty dope all right i'll give it
another shot and came around looks like
theo a little bit
uh yeah patrick mahomes and theovan had
a baby
how about that game last night i was
on monday i'm sorry monday it's
wednesday mount
i know well i just we didn't talk about
the baltimore ravens versus
what else you got jen oh speaking of
sports
chianti johnson who who was uh put in a
medically induced coma
right i guess he's awake now and talking
to his family
yeah oh i forgot yeah
he was a cheerleader male cheerleader
but he wasn't he was a badass like you
were
like really good really amazing tumbling
i became a real big fan of cheerleading
after that documentary cheer
yeah how do you feel about jerry that
one yeah that's true
dapping up like yeah was jerry your
favorite character yeah he was
me too bro he had a problematic part
recently right that's me
wow it looks like wesley snipes
but look at him legit
how crazy is that damn bro can you do
some of that stuff still or what
not all of it yeah you they'll ask him
to do a backflip on stage every time
yeah
i always wanted to just learn like one
back black flit
backflip i got it right
that's what i call mine
i felt so shitty i'm like looking at his
black dude doing backflips i'm like
black flip you had it right
that's what i called it
i'd love to get mounted oh my god
yeah they're so tough to do man just
like it just seemed like a good party
trick or something just like
you really liked the docu-series cheer
yeah that was dope yeah so i i cheered
at the
school that competed against them the
rivalry yeah i was the right
their rival yeah but uh in it like jerry
was my favorite character
and like he blew up he was on ellen
everybody loved jerry though
how could you not yeah he was on every
[ __ ] podcast he was on tv shows
hosting the oscars and then [ __ ] [ __ ]
came out
oh my gosh bro maybe maybe they do that
for the one case a game
seven but it's getting bad that's gonna
be a meanwhile every 15 to 30 years
wow wow that he's going to have a tough
time in jail
oh yeah minimum 15. that's the worst
possible person
no i think he's going to flourish no i
will not dude
my dad's childhood oh yeah
see i'm thinking i forgot yeah yeah i'm
thinking he's just going to suck the
boys off in the yard
no that's the worst title to having yeah
yeah it's gonna be the worst
targeted the word yeah it's not gonna be
pretty for that dude quit saying that's
my boy
you you won in the cheer world bro you
really won
oh you did it you really did it
yeah jerry thing man 30.
that's why it's crazy yeah i don't know
it was like yeah
everyone was rooting for [ __ ] in the
series all right your boy
david chappelle there she fell you know
how he's been
he did that little skit or or that bit
where he's talking about how they're
yeah they're using his show and not
paying him
and netflix netflix pulled it and now
hbo plus or hbo max pulled it as well
the power of dave should be yeah
but why wouldn't he just say like just
give me the money the proceeds from it
instead of points i don't think they
would do that
i think he did ask at the very end he
said please don't use my
stuff until they start paying me
properly that's a boss [ __ ] right there
though
[ __ ] for hbo yo
they they know it's gonna be a bad look
for them to not talk
off you know what i'm saying and they
did it because he's so highly loved
and netflix did it too yeah yeah
that's something about how much power
you have to like this the
probably the funniest sketcher of all
time i know you just got the catalog
don't air it because it hurts my
feelings they didn't pay me for it yeah
that's such a boss movie i don't know if
anybody else could do that because the
whole [ __ ] is that like
they're allowed to do that contractually
to keep it he signed the deal yeah
exactly exactly but his explanation was
really good too about that system
that's broken along he was saying like
the lawyers exactly if they're in the
same
club oh yeah you know what i mean yeah
it's like
i understood that part the way he
explained it yeah he was saying because
they're basically like you scratch my
back i'll scratch yours that kind of
same agenda
yeah yeah which i guess one's
representing him so it's conflict of
interest
yeah and and all stuff he's doing is
gonna be like a learning lesson for a
lot of young people oh yeah so
you know yeah he just drops so much
[ __ ] knowledge so does that mean we
won't be able to watch the chappelle
show anywhere
until they pay him i don't know oh you
can buy it on amazon
i want i doubt he sees money off we just
got to bootleg it that's it
see that's why i think he should leave
it on the network and just get paid
because more people will be exposed to
it they can
enjoy it and he'll get the money from it
but i get the whole
house but they're not paying him so he
would have to report but why doesn't
that yeah as i'm saying
here's however many millions that's what
i think we're going to do
you know because they should i mean i
don't know if they've done that you know
what i mean but
because technically he he doesn't own it
he doesn't know yeah
so they so comedy central whoever you
probably wouldn't get the money
netflix owns it either they're just
licensing oh that's true
but i think champions so if they worked
oh yeah yeah they worked negotiating
exactly the production to pay them to
pay him yeah
then we all have like this beautiful you
know what one comedy show
house can have no choice but yeah we got
to pay him otherwise
nobody's going to pick it up yeah i
think they should do that but they can
go they could all meet at the same table
renegotiate a deal like yo listen yeah
for all parties involved
let's just get this job done instead of
taking it away from the world the world
deserves yeah this is
the world should have that or that
production house says [ __ ] all y'all
we're releasing on youtube for free
that's still good for him too yeah
well they do have the youtube clips of
the show yeah but not
the full episodes yeah all right i saw
this and i thought it was
i'm sure it's a sad one well okay if you
like carjackers it's sad but
these guys try to carjack this guy and
this guy actually reversed back and oh
ran these guys over which is kind of
controversial but this is i think you
know deserves trying to jack his car
try and jack him yeah i'm not good at
watching you die though like this
oh yeah dory i think they're all fine
so you see this guy trying to get in his
car and they were writing a moped
right so they're about to bounce these
guys come back and then the guy was like
you know what screw this i'm gonna get
these guys
and then [ __ ] oh wow
wow oh my god
so that's you know not even much damage
to the club yeah
oh [ __ ] then he stopped there still
trying to run him over this is yeah
i think he was just he where was the
[ __ ] moment poetic justice right that
looks like
or something like that i don't know what
yeah it didn't seem like that was here
yeah it's very very like they don't give
you that many no there's no two men on a
scooter in america
you know why why the world thing yeah
all the things in like those countries
two dudes
seven miles instead of looking real damn
bad
oh my lord have you guys heard of
jackson he
who jackson he i guess apparently he's
the first
chinese-born football player for this
league the f fbs do you know
college football college football
t-double-a yeah and uh just
look how lovable this guy is i'll just
play for you real quick
so he made history here that's him there
yeah right here asian running back yeah
boom so you made that touchdown i like
that
[Applause]
so what's the what's the um because he's
the first chinese-born
ever yeah to ever do it they said they
believe he is the first they don't
they're not like a hundred percent sure
of course we wouldn't follow them and
they allow it to challenge chinese yeah
they allow them to have that on their
own wow that's dope that's so cool
that's kind of wild that that's the
first ever yeah right yeah
dude like i would because what was that
gwen that was vietnamese yeah
yeah we have like america was korean he
was actually
also had like heinz ward who has a half
past yeah
oh but he really leaned into it that the
korean
yeah he did he was probably like all
right
all right the thing it's weird because
there are a lot of half
asian and half black like artists and
music but they don't really lean into
the asian part
because like tyga is half asian yeah oh
he is
yeah yeah he grew up in the mountains
yeah and and it's like you don't and
there's
more there's like several other but i
understand today does lean into the age
i did not know that about it coconut was
his favorite first song bro
that should let you the [ __ ] does that
have to do with it it's like that's a
thai dish and i don't know
literally come on
you mix it all up all right so please
real quick the football
in a college game good looking kid too i
don't know what to say
like uh it's not me it's all the
diamonds in front of me
i caught in the gray wall because they
protect me
i don't know what was yours he was born
in china that moved here
yeah he's like likable so likeable
on the asu website won't load because so
many people are going to it to find out
more about you what do you want those
people to know about you
uh i mean it's pleasant man thank you
for all the support and love man
uh you know it's just a start i just
want to i wanted to know like chinese
get ball
too you know yeah if you want people to
know about you
that jersey you might want to change it
i don't know how i'm going to look that
up like off of jersey [ __ ]
but you know in china they were [ __ ]
oh yeah
another one yeah yeah
uh let's do this one so this girl who's
she worked as an emt and wanted to make
ends meet because she wasn't making
enough money with the
at the emt job so she did her only fans
and then i guess she wanted to be
you know anonymous and when she talked
to new york posts but they put her name
out
so they kind of you know put her out
there in the world
so everyone's going against the new york
post for saying that you know
she was on all the fans she's making a
living very pretty she's making a living
yeah aoc went um yeah she did too
commented about
this too she was like yo chill bro like
if
the fact that medics have to take on
another job just to make it happen
[Applause]
yeah bro i'll kick somebody in the face
uh she's very attractive too
yeah she's very beautiful i'm going to
support
everybody get over that
she bad but this is like i think there's
like a twitter thing that she did
i love my titties yeah so that's
she says she can take a look at him at
her only fence oh wow this is good
marketing oh i like i bet you i bet you
sure her account is popping now
of course dude oh probably is yeah yeah
she has a support of all the fans
i know yeah and she probably quit that
emt job
yeah i'm sorry i don't know all right
well [ __ ] she might have fired her
that's what i'm saying or yeah or they
fired her yeah she's probably making
more money
anyway right no yeah most likely if it's
popping for sure
i heard a lot of girls don't actually
make money off of only fans
unless they have a following because
it's kind of hard to make get your first
couple of followers
oh well with this post but something
like this yeah something like this she
should be doing well
yeah all right good for her shout out
yeah
so stop shaming people for being an only
fan yeah yeah do what you do uh
emt start your own chin's only fan
uh this is just another quick one did
you know mark hunt fought this
past weekend i think underneath the
heavyweight card
no this he did it in a boxing match and
he lost to this uh rugby player
part-time amateur fighter yeah i mean
he's a pro fight but he was like he's a
part-time fighter what main event was
this uh did they say or no
uh it was on a boxing car i forgot which
one it was is that it all right
no there's no knockout he just lost okay
yeah oh it says rapid knockout
that's for the other dude yeah yeah
ten to zero but yeah mark hunt fought
over the last few days and
he lost a rugby player jesus in boxing
but he did
uh decision or knocked out decision [ __ ]
dude
and then i saw mark actually played yeah
crazy right and he has no fight no he
has some fights
he's undefeated but still yeah
paul gallon [ __ ] sakes all right shout
out to he's louise
you want another one are you guys good
uh just one more
uh this guy so he's suspended
up the ref yeah that this blind side of
the referee the high school player
so he can't play anymore it was terrible
he looks like an [ __ ] too
i know right how
so he can't play for any high school
sports any high school sports no he's
[ __ ] dude yeah
he going to jail i don't know it says
arrested but i don't know if he's going
to be on jail
oh jesus man yeah that's what he gets
though you know
yeah that's the douchebag move well what
can you do what can you do
dumbfounded we appreciate dude yeah
thanks for having me man it was fun yeah
yeah yeah
you begin listing your podcasts off the
itunes fun with dumb
um just look up fun with dumb and all
the you know platforms and youtube too
it's video too so you can go to
youtube.com
fun with dumb thanks for having me
appreciate it thank you
last battle i'll ever do was right here
yes history thanks for entertaining it
super sus battle yes
let's see next week is christmas the
week after uh
end this horrible 2020 with your boys
here win west palm beach florida
uh palm beach improv december 31st
through january
2nd come see the squad out there take
you to t5k.com
and then just uh drop san marcos texas
it's right outside
austin texas uh four shows
uh two shows friday two show saturday
these will sell out limited capacity san
marcos texas
at the mark out there in san marcos
texas tickets at t5k.com
thick boy smiley gear drops friday night
at midnight
thickboy.com the new uh thick boy smiley
i'll be blasting out you guys to see it
thickboy.com for this friday at midnight
thickboy.com
is that it fellas yeah we love you we're
out yes sir